you're going to be absolutely disgusted
when you hear how evil this company is
in the 1930s a certain American company
made products out of aluminum like
airplane parts and stuff like that but
manufacturing aluminum is a messy
process that produces chemicals like
fluoride a super toxic man-made version
of fluoride it Heats through concrete
glass stainless steel and it causes a
lot of bad things like cancer and brain
damage the problem was that fluoride was
too expensive to dispose of in a
responsible way so what did this company
do they piped it into the air and dumped
it in the river it was the 1930s after
all no one cared so they poisoned our
air and water supply for decades when
people started to notice all the
terrible side effects this company was
about to be drowned in lawsuits but then
they did something genius they pushed
the narrative that fluoride is good for
your teeth it prevents cavities which is
why today the government puts fluoride
in our water supply free of charge click
the link in the pinned comment to watch
the video on the evil history of
fluoride